[MUSIC]
Bill Winters,
CEO of Standard Chartered Bank welcome to
Stanford into the Industrialist Dilemma.
>> It's great to be here.
>> Tell us a little bit about how the bank
has changed since you took over a little
over five years ago?
It's been an odyssey, I will say.
So I was brought in, I had left banking,
I didn't think I'd be
going back into banking.
And when I got the call to
come into Standard Chartered,
I knew that the bank was
having some troubles.
I didn't know,
quite how large the problems were.
But there was something fascinating to
me about Standard Chartered, which was,
I believed that, and
turns out I was right on this one.
Very good customer franchise, great brand,
fantastic presence in the fastest
growing markets in the world, right?
Asia, Africa, Middle East all that.
I knew that the bank had gotten
a bit over overextended in terms
of credit commitments and had some losses.
And I knew that the bank had had some
problems with financial crime compliance.
Whenever the chairman of a company calls
up and says, would you like to come in and
be the CEO?
The old CEO is leaving,
you know it's not perfect.
It's a clue.
And so, and I took the job,
and I haven't regretted it for a day
since, I'll tell you, but it has changed.
The bank has changed a lot,
and I've changed a lot,
I learned a lot during that time.
First and foremost, what I found was that
there had been a period of maybe seven or
eight years, for
the bank had done phenomenally well,
at least phenomenally well in
terms of the reported figures.
But it was also trading at a big premium
to every other bank in the market,
and the reason was that it had
generated consistent top line and
bottom line growth over a five year
period, which wasn't surprising given
the markets where we were operating
which were growing very fast.
In banking, one thing you must be worried
about is things that grow too fast.
And especially if the growth
is coming from lending.
Because at some point the controls
get loose problems come in.
So I assumed that that's what had
happened at Standard Chartered, it was.
And when I came in, I immediately imposed
a much more aggressive system of controls,
which was 80% the right thing to do and
20% the wrong thing to do.
Right because the bank did need
to sort of quantum adjustment.
The wrong thing to do because,
what I didn't realize was how risk
averse the bank had already become.
In the year or so before I arrived, they
realized the problems that were there and
had already put the brakes on.
I came in and hit the brakes harder,
and we've probably adjusted too much.
>> Right.
>> So we went through a period of
18 months of very aggressive cost cutting,
very aggressive sort of reckoning
with prior control lapses and
very heavy investment in things where
we had under invested for some time.
Another way to make your numbers look
good is to not invest in your business.
And we hadn't invested in the basics,
control infrastructure, technology,
we had big technology deficit.
So the first 18 months was cleanup.
We called it securing the foundations,
and we did that.
The next 18 months was positioning
the bank for growth again.
And a little bit like, I suppose when
somebody has had a horrific accident and
they've lost the ability to walk,
when they relearn they actually
have to train their brain,
train their legs, train the body to learn
how to shift the weight the right way.
And we had a little bit
of that to go through.
And we did, we made good steady progress.
And my last, it'll be five years in June,
so my last year and a half or so
has been, you're taking this body that
had learned how to walk again, and
then trying to run, and trying to run and
keep pace with the market.
That's-
>> That's the journey.
So in the parts of the world where
Standard Chartered has a big
footprint-
>> Yeah.
>> Asia, Southeast Asia,
Africa, a lot of volatility.
And in particular, if you look at
the relationships between China and
the US, how do these dynamics in
a volatile world impact your business?
>> Standard Chattered has been around for
160 years, and I would venture to say, in
any one of those 160 years, there's been
a major crisis in at least one of our
70 or 80 markets where we operate.
And in many cases,
I think of the Asian financial crisis or
obviously the great financial crisis,
A crisis has been in all those markets.
So, we have a tag line which is at
the bottom of my business card and
it's here for good, well,
Standard Chattered.
It's a nice double entendre, which
obviously means we're here to do good.
And it also means that we come and stay.
And so, we've left very few
places in those 160 years.
And we left Iran, we left Afghanistan,
that might be about it.
And we're still in Zimbabwe,
where we can say shame on us.
But anyway, we are the bank in Zimbabwe.
So, we're used to volatility,
and we're used to,
in fact that's in our DNA to take a long
term view through volatile periods.
So when we look at, I mean last year
the two largest exhaustion or shocks for
us were the deterioration
in US-China trade.
We are a global trade bank.
We have a very big business in China,
we are the biggest international bank
carrying U.S dollars, second biggest.
So we got a big US business,
that's a problem for us.
And we contemplate a world where both
China and the U.S byforcade fundamentally,
we are all thinking about that,
you are thinking about it here,
and, yeah, we'd be a very different
bank in that environment.
And what do we need to do to prepare for
that?
Because at the end of the day,
we want to remain a very,
very important bank in China and a very
important bank in the United States.
The protests in Hong Kong,
Hong Kong is our single biggest market.
Our name is on the banknotes in Hong Kong.
And Hong Kong shut down for six months or
certainly shut down completely for
three months and
was stressed for three months.
Hong Kong is going to be okay.
And Hong Kong is going to come out the
back end of this, it will be different.
People will say to me,
they'll look at me very earnestly and say,
Hong Kong will never be the same.
Hong Kong never was the same.
Hong Kong is one of the most
dynamic places on the planet,
it changes all the time, and it was
going to change again, in some ways for
the worse, in some ways for the better,
it's a very resilient place.
Let's focus on those things that will
represent the future of Hong Kong.
Let's invest in those and
let's make sure we're there for that.
>> So speaking of volatility,
and even Hong Kong,
you set up some digital activities
in a digital bank based in Asia.
Tell us a little bit about
those activities and
where you see that headed over
the next five to ten years.
>> One of the things I find very
exciting about Standard Chartered,
which I think would be off putting for
a lot of people.
We are not a big bank.
We're a mid sized bank, but we're global.
And when I talk to shareholders or
others about Standard Chartered,
they'll frequently say, do you think
you can compete given your scale?
I mean, how can you compete with
HSBC who's much bigger than you?
JP Morgan, where I worked for
25 years, it was much bigger than you.
How can you compete?
The answer is, in short, well, we can't
compete if we're competing on scale.
So we've got to compete on something else.
And we compete on being very local,
whereas not everybody
is as local as we are.
We compete on having
element of global scale.
So we have a global network which
is unique to Standard Chartered,
all across Africa, all across South Asia,
every Asian country, et cetera.
But we also need to be
prepared to be more nimble
than these people who
are much bigger than we are.
It isn't necessarily in our DNA.
I mean,
this is a trait that we've got to acquire.
But we are in a position in many
of our markets to be a disrupter.
>> Right.
>> And
we can be the disrupter who actually has a
brand, who has a physical infrastructure,
who has licenses, who has good
relationships with regulators.
We're also a highly desirable partner.
So in Hong Kong, we partnered
with Hong Kong Telecom and Secha.
Hong Kong telecom is the ubiquitous
Telco provider, fixed and mobile,
as well as media.
And Secha Pacific is a travel
agent of the world entirely online
obviously based in China,
but very big in Hong Kong.
So with these partners,
we can offer an extremely disruptive model
in our home market right now, of course,
why would we disrupt ourselves?
Because it's going to be disrupted one way
or the other, and we want to make sure
that we are positioned to be a not just a
survivor, but a thriver in the new market.
And we're also focusing on
a segment of the market which is
probably less penetrated,
which is the mass market.
So we're building a digital
bank in Hong Kong,
I would hope that we're in a position
to do something similar in Singapore,
which is another one of our home markets.
We got very interesting
partnerships in China with
some of the tech behemoths who really
want to capture part of the financial
services profitability without
being a regulated bank, so
there's opportunities for us to
partner in digital initiatives there.
We have a venture lab that
is in the process of,
we just partnered up with
a group out of Australia that is
getting into the merchant acquiring
business across Southeast Asia.
Yeah, this is a start up, it's a distinct
venture within our organization.
So it doesn't have to deal with any
of the Standard Chartered legacy.
But it gets to leverage all
the Standard Chartered competence.
It get funny that I hank out my,
talking with the Hong Kong Virtual Bank
team who said,
we're separate from the rest of the bank,
we're in a fancy, we work style location,
we operate in the valley way.
But, sometimes the bank can insinuate
itself into our processes and
policies make us though, I can see that.
Let's see how we can work through that.
And who is the competition, right?
When we're competing with Alibaba,
we're competing with Sanghan.
They don't have the problem,
their mothership it doesn't have
this regulated bureaucracy.
Okay, so I guess they're going to
launch way before we will,
because they can sort of move so
much faster.
They said no no, we're probably
going to launch ahead of them.
So, why is that?
Well, what they don't have is the systems
that can do the customer's due diligence,
and know your client.
>> Right.
>> Sort of checking up front.
And we can just do a drag and drop out
of the main bank into the Virtual Bank.
And say, I get it.
So we are able to save six months of
development time because we actually
invest in a couple billion dollars into
the world class compliance system.
Whether we love the fact that
we have to do that or not,
it doesn't matter, we have it.
And the other guys don't have that,
they're going to have to
build that out themselves.
>> It's an interesting
dynamic you just described.
You look at the history of the bank,
follow started by two
people from Scotland.
Largely doing business in Africa and
throughout Asia, and
you talked about being
in the local market.
How do you think about that?
How should the world view
Standard Chartered Bank?
Where is your local market, and
where are your home markets?
You're based in London, how do you
communicate that to the rest of the world?
>> It's a challenge, and when I think
about the structural challenges and
disadvantages that we have, we don't
the single big profitable home market.
We are very big in Hong Kong,
it's about a third of our profitability.
But if you look at other big global banks,
HSBC is 80% or
something greater in China,
JP Morgan IS 80% US.
And DBS, which is the big bank
in Singapore is 80% Singapore.
So, on the one hand, there's our challenge
and we don't have that home market that
they can sort of feed the profits
into other markets as you're growing.
And so we've got to find ways to be
creative and innovative in other ways to
leverage the fact that actually what
we have is a network that's unique.
So, I mean the two Scottish guys they
planted a lot of flags back in 1858.
>> So one final question for you,
if we look forward ten years from now,
if you and I are sitting here in 2030,
what do you think the bank looks like
then, what are the biggest differences and
what will be the same?
>> Yeah, we do this kind of
exercise from time to time and
we said what was finance
going to look like?
And we've got this simplistic view that
the transactional elements of finance will
be what we drive into community platforms.
And we are either going to own or
partially own some of those platforms,
which some of them have
already taken over the world.
So it's unlikely that we're
going to be owning a ubiquitous
platform in China anytime soon, or
we're going to be providing services
in terms of the mass market.
And in terms of that
transaction element to banking,
we're going to be providing
services into that.
And those services
are going to be databased.
So our massive investment has been in
enabling digital services that
the data enlightened, and
we've got a lot of examples where
this is working really well for us.
But it's a very different kind of model.
Thankfully in that segment of the market
today, we don't make much money.
So we don't have a lot
of stake at stake there.
There's another part of
the financial life though,
that will have a heavy
element of trust and advice.
And I think when individuals
are thinking about their health,
their wealth, their retirement and
the education of their children,
maybe the purchase of their home,
major life decisions.
I think for a long time after the computer
is smarter than than the human being,
will still want to have
some human interaction.
And we're making that bet.
We've got that brand.
So we're leveraging that brand locally and
investing in that trust asset heavily, and
all the digital tools that go around that.
And I think that applies to a big
chunk of the corporate business.
We're roughly half retail
half corporate roughly.
And our corporate clients rely on us
to execute a whole range of things, but
mostly cross border things.
And we're a cross border network bank.
And we've got this this network, and
we can imagine a world where regulation in
Africa is the same as regulation in China,
is the same as regulation in Korea,
but we're not there now.
And we're not going to be there,
I think in my lifetime or
maybe even your lifetime.
So, there's complexity that comes from
helping companies work on a global stage.
Those complexities are getting greater,
not lesser,
with anti globalization movements and
trade barriers and nationalism.
And we're excellent at
navigating those things.
So this is good getting back into the,
not so much the transactional part of
the financial services, but something
where you have some unique insight.
So 30 years from now we'll
be delivering that package.
>> The lack of a home base
might actually be an asset.
And an unfair competitive advantage for
you going forward because you'll
understand the broader
geographical issues.
>> Maybe.
>> All right, Bill Winter, CEO,
Standard Chartered, thank you so
much for coming to Stanford,
a pleasure to have you here.
>> Thank you for having me.
[MUSIC]